bene tutti ragazzi permette questo video
sono fa dj oggi siamo tornati su io sono
il pane ancora ragazzi devo abituarmi a
chiamarlo così perché merida chiamarlo
pane simulator più o meno prova bene
lavori ma sti ragazzi che lavori oggi
alla palla bedroom quindi alla stanza da
letto e non voglio cercare di capire che
cazzo ci fa un tosto in una stanza da
letto però ecco perché ci siamo piano
che devono capire un attimo ascoltami
gatto ho capito le sei messo comodo però
ecco infatti i nove seriamente che cosa
ci faceva ok by gatto vagliato e che
conquistiamo al mondo comunque ragazzi
la cosa che gli sto gioco è difficile
non è tanto arrampicarsi e tutto quanto
ma la difficoltà sta nel trovare in
commercio stare esto pane nel secondo
gela televisore cielo vito stallo con
televisori composto tostarlo con il
computer mi chiami no non ci credo
sono vivo io vivo su suo vice spiderman
fai vedere chi sei ma maledizione calmi
niente sono caduto alto caldo caldo
caldo [ __ ] sapeva in treno sul
muro noah eccoli lì era pulito per
carità ma ci fosse pare non cessino
non voglio non voglio scoprire ripensato
non voglio scoprirlo no no no no no no
no no ma spetta ai sporca e lo sapevo
che la sua ancora f come favi gf come
[ __ ] non è così semplice come pensavo
che
[Musica]
come fisicamente possibile una cosa così
dice ora io io sto volando con un altro
pezzo di passiamo innamorati così tanto
che vogliamo che cazzo succedere ok ok
bene non voglio sapere che cosa appena
successo però mi è piaciuto in fisica
non è che sono sempre stato un fenomeno
però non credo funzioni così ok si
stanno stuprando a vicenda finché non ha
timori se il pane nuovi no no non
mollarlo no no non posso perderti o la
parola stronzo vola fai qualcosa non è
possibile vai vai se inutile al bene
proprio inutile al bene schifo che
schifo a terra che schifo goda fai
qualcosa attaccate perfetto abbiamo
fatto dei chilometri ragazzi va bene
così se riesco a sopravvivere senza
morire che nervi quando noi e scassa ok
devo andare al computer prima che devo
cuocere questo bel posto che è bello
pulito soprattutto che schifo come no
come sporco il muro veramente non posso
andare sul muro perché sporco ma
[ __ ] neve ma se questo punto è più
pulito invece ai maledizione non ce la
farà non ce la facessi se ti blocchi
pure tua sorella mortadella cavo bra
madonna madonna un fenomeno un fenomeno
ragazzo mio dio e tipo un insetto
madonna è peggio cioè se vede una roba
così sul mio muro la schiaccia
indipendentemente che sia un pane una
pizza come volete piano 2 in chiaro non
ci arriva
si è già fatta ha vinto tutto vinto
tutto dalla vita propri sono caramelle
ma dopo le maggior piccolo queste nuovo
serio ma posso mettermi ok
certo mi sono messo nei questo è un tot
caramella ovviamente per una stiro cazzo
non ci ha ripensato non è il computer mi
sa che il ferro da stiro cioè la cosa
che costa di più tra queste due cose
credo sia afferma ragazze se mi lancio
c'è il rischio che io cade a terra ma ma
[ __ ] e ci provo ci provo
sì l'ho preso
[Musica]
sopra madonna capirà che mira solo su
maledizione caramelle pesano le
caramelle pesano i casinò perfetto ciò
fatta non ce l'ho fatta ancora se non ce
la faremo mai rega no non ci crederò mai
nella vita non ci crederò mai nella
[ __ ] vita non voglio premere timori
se il pulcino pio listino la famiglia
giuro dai vai vai vai vai no no la parte
no siamo appunto ea capo che cazzo serve
fare così c'hai un futuro da elicottero
credo non ce la farò mai
c'è la tazza la caccia li mortacci della
tazza mica ci godo come non ha idea
proprio di morire anche peggio ci posso
credere veloce ma dormo non un altro ad
un'altra volta non è giura che come
finisco di falsa roba vado in cucina
spaccato tentazione che ciò stesso da
ragazzi è un gioco dove comando un pezzo
di pane
rendetevi capensis era un gioco di
guerra che cazzo succede comunque male è
che traction come fottutamente mi sono
salvato non lo so ma vai vai vai mai
allora allora prima di fare una cagata
vediamo di fare una roba seria bene bene
o male senza del salto della madonna la
senti nell'aria questo eun sun non
quello di prima che mi campo un po
defecato ma certi come cazzo fate godo
godo la vita e cosa serviva al computer
giusto per capire ai ffd fa vj semplice
l'ho fatta ma la vita propria asta
lampada impossibile cosa stai facendo
tra pane che vola e lampade che ci hanno
vita propria non voglio sapere che cosa
continua sto gioco è il bagno bathroom
come faccio a costare un pezzo di pane
in bagno come ci sarà un phon
minchia magari ci ho azzeccato temi
vedere come sto bagno perché è la madama
che ha schifo lo shampoo di cristiano
ronaldo lo posso anche tipo no
mortacci tua ma l'acqua non sporca
l'acqua è buona ma hai mangiato dal pan
bagnato è normale ero dove devo andare
però sti cazzi
mi chiede se va bene anche sarah crowe
bazzi a livelli e pc legherei forza che
ci affacciamo si schiacciano quasi bravo
mio dio mi chiese diventato un vero
grazie bravissimo la medaglia d'oro
voglio cambi che c'è il fondamento il
fondi già lo sa io sto scherzando prima
anche un po dal cesto il problema è che
se cado nel cesso potrebbero essere
problemi
bye bye bye bye bye bye perfetto perché
no
madonna santissima impossibile se cado
no no no no no dall'altra parte no ma lì
ma se dico di là [ __ ] non ci credo
utilità nel cesso perché è stato tragico
le paperelle le voglio non devo toccare
l'acqua giusto perché poi un intoppo non
sa come ci si fa insozzare con l'acqua
ma ok assai shampoo per capelli e spalle
le mie spalle hanno i capelli quindi c'è
lo shampoo per le sparute mi dispiace
sacco vuol dio ti amavo
[Musica]
vabbè il secco no no
minchia che cazzo di sapone è quello che
ho fatto non ci posso credere
ci sono arrivato ora me no sì sì tosta
tosta premere il tasto del termosifone
questo qui ma no no è [ __ ]
io ci credo no non ci credono mai non ci
credo veloce ma cazzo ma guarda che
schifo si ce l'ho fatta
calmi che no sono caduto non ci credo no
no no no no no no no no no non lo si 4
per cento no non posso non c'è invece sì
non l'ho preso malizia quasi però no no
no no non è possibile non è possibile
portarci del termosifone riguarda sua
merda circa c'è roba che chi se mi
impegnavo non ci riuscivo giuro si sia
acceso davvero ma vuol dire che se non
ci credo non ci fosse che era il suo era
il [ __ ] faella che cazzo ha
funzionato prima non voglio neanche
saperlo
le soddisfazioni di un videogioco sono
poche ma questa la rappresenta ed è
anche abbastanza per noi domani ragazzi
prova fatti potrei incazzarmi potrei
alter armi fino a ucciderti la famiglia
questa è una cosa che ti dico bravo vedo
che ha capito non fossimo blog faccio un
posto così io non veramente provo a fare
un tosto che lì perché devo capire se
effettivamente una cosa che può
funzionare
non fatelo a casa comunque non si sa mai
e feliz fa vj e vinciamo qualsiasi cosa
ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi fate vedere
non ce l'ho io giuro giusto per capire
che cosa dovrà darmi assorbire l'ultimo
bagno come insomma come cominciò ancora
uscito ha vinto quindi mancano sabato
domenica
ora hanno ancora fatto ho preso un
punteggio da dio da dio su ogni livello
quindi ragazzi che ho incluso che
l'episodio più produrre le scrivo gli
altri livelli posso ritenermi
soddisfatto di aver finito un gioco che
merita la volpe il nemico games del 2014
veramente fantastico e quindi ragazzi se
il video è piaciuto ma sento lasciato
commento mi piace anche a passare
facebook e come la nevicata descrizione
stasera vestiti silenti ci vediamo il
prossimo video delle ragazze